America has had 39 mass shootings that
is more than any of the last five
januaries in this country and according
to the gun violence archive which tracks
this kind of thing we are now on Pace to
outpace last year's total of
647 mass shootings the definition by the
way is four or more victims not
including the gunman and yes this is a
uniquely American problem we have more
than eight times the rate of gun
violence deaths in this country as in
Canada and nearly a hundred times more
than Britain according to one survey
guys the U.S is the only country in the
world where there are more guns than
there are people so it is very bad and
it is very unique to us